n was founded by Satoshi Nakamoto now
this is actually just a pseudonym we
don't know whether Satoshi is one person
or a group of people and that's the
beauty of it the first smartest thing
that Satoshi Nakamoto did was creating
Bitcoin the second part that he or she
or they whatever did was disappearing in
2010 it's so important that they
disappeared Ross alri is the individual
that created the dark web on this dark
web it's called Silk Road they were
trading in Bitcoin and many different
things and so this individual is now
serving several life sentences in jail
just because of the capacity of what was
created on this website those at the top
and the CIA weren't okay with it they
weren't okay with this type of
marketplace existing then how on Earth
are they going to be okay with Bitcoin
with Satoshi Nakamoto creating an
alternative monetary Network which
literally makes the central banks who by
the way control the world completely
Obsolete and redundant the second
smartest thing the founder of Bitcoin
did was disappearing Satoshi Nakamoto
could be 1 2 3 4 100 people we don't
even know so those at the top don't even
know who to look for